hey man's meet kevin smith uh we're
going to do a little scene study today
from clerks and it's the uh jane silent
bob's
final scene in the movie the scene where
santa bob speaks
uh where jay and bob have their
conversation with dante
so you're going to see jason muse and
you see kevin smith and you're going to
see brian o'halleran
um this scene existed in every version
of the script the first draft all the
way up to shooting and stuff
there's always meant to be this
crossover moment in the earlier drafts
there's a lot more information about
what jay is doing next like in the movie
he goes i'm going over this party in
atlantic
get rip hopefully get laid and [ __ ] and
he invites dante to the party
that party uh in atlantic
was where he would then cross over
with johnny no he johnny the guy who
kills him kills dante spoilers
in the first cut of clerks met jay
outside and he was like you i'm gonna go
to the party man you're gonna meet me at
the party
like and john was like yeah yeah and
he's like you know
john wanted to buy drugs from jay's
character jay
was like you got no money you got to get
money and [ __ ] essentially jay
instigated johnny needing money which
sent him into quick stop at the end of
the movie
to kill dante so jay was kind of
recklessly responsible for the death of
dante
and uh originally in this scene that
kind of
you could it was the seeds were sewn you
could kind of see it and stuff
but this is uh of course the scene where
uh cinema history was changed forever
kids i was not intended to speak
in clerks at all silent bob wasn't
intended to speak i wasn't intended to
play son of bob i was gonna play randall
that's why he's got all the best jokes
but uh i wound up playing solo bob and
something he was never meant to have a
line
but we were shooting that sequence and
jay couldn't spit out the [ __ ] line
couldn't do the lasagna line and chill
like that so i was like you know what
[ __ ] i will just
i'll do it you know and then i you know
i was like there's a million i was like
did you just [ __ ] leave
and say goodbye and go like get uh i'm
getting out of here and [ __ ]
um he had lived uh the [ __ ] uh slur
that he throws at uh
at brian holland i checked all my
scripts that wasn't in there that's pure
j
young j so he leaves and then i [ __ ]
you know rocked the line only did it
because jay couldn't spit out
the line so changed
my life changed cinema history for me at
least because then silent bob
forevermore would
have one moment at least where he said
something not so silent
um that all came from jay's inability to
spit out my stupid dialogue
so let's take a look at what that uh how
that turned out man
the jay and sam bob finale scene from
clerks
[Music]
noise noise smoking weed smoking weed
doing coke drink your beers packer
asthma go man
time to kick back drinks your [ __ ] and
smoke some weed done poisoning the youth
for today huh
hell's yes whatever that means now it's
time to head over to atlantic
drink some beers get ripped and
hopefully get laid
179. paid a good man
yeah you close soon in half an hour yeah
we get off the same time every day we
should hang out you get high
i should start you wanna come this part
with me today there's gonna be some
[ __ ] there man
with you i don't think so oh look you i
don't hang out with drug dealers
nothing personal yeah what happened with
that old guy
he died in the bathroom well i heard he
was jerking off or something
i don't know i wasn't watching yeah he
probably saw i can't check i know i felt
like beating him when i saw her
oh come here [ __ ] you like this huh huh
that's what you want
hey knock it off that used to be my
girlfriend all right i used to go out
with her
yeah well i thought we might be starting
again they already have a girlfriend
yeah veronica and what you're gonna dump
her for that cannon chick
maybe i don't know dude that can just
nice but i see that veronica real doing
[ __ ] for you all the time
i started rubbing your back [ __ ] come
brings your food
did i see you change your tire once but
hey you know i jacked up the car all she
did was unloosen the nuts and put the
tire on
i know she does a lot for you she's my
girlfriend
i have some girlfriends too but all they
wanted for me was reading [ __ ]
[ __ ] my grandma used to say what's
better [ __ ] a
good play with nothing on it no wait i
[ __ ] up what's a good play with
nothing
on it meaning oh no she was seeing all
[ __ ] she used to [ __ ] push herself
all the time
and [ __ ] herself come on samba let's get
the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] jib joint
with this [ __ ] dante you [ __ ] smoker
you know there's a million fine looking
women in the world dude but they don't
all bring you lasagna at work
most of them just cheat on you come on
let's dick
he's right hey kids did you like that
all these movies are available on itunes
or netflix in some places
amazon and other places you can find
them they're available
patronize them if you will uh also if
you like this kind of stuff
come on over to that kevin smith club go
to thatkevinsmithclub.com
join up man i do wake and bake three
times a week where i wake up just smoke
weed with you all and stuff
come to that kevin smith club for more
video antics with kevin smith